our tester is taking the spacious and
luxurious bentley flying spur out for a
spin
this extravagant sedan boasts adjustable
air suspension and four-wheel drive it's
an entry-level Bentley so to speak
flying stars artistic I know Dyson /
says the car's name is steeped in
tradition it's almost banaa to mention
the sedan 6-liter 12 cylinder engine
with an output of 632 horsepower its
powertrain is practically inaudible as
the Bentley glides along majestically
and passengers ponder whether they
themselves should be at the wheel or
relax on the back seat food fun and ZEB
style game artists in Germany this
luxurious sedan will set you back 190
1000 euros all Bentley's are
characterized by a quietly elegant
exterior the grille and headlights are
kept in a classical design is powerful
yet quiet 12-cylinder engine is tucked
away underneath the hood producing a
maximum torque of 800 Newton metres from
2,000 rpm it's enough to leave any
competitor in the dust
customers can choose from 100 different
colors of body paint on offer are 11
shades of black 16 kinds of gray and 75
types of blue red and green Bentley
clients have many options but the
Bentley is not just a smooth ride it's a
racer as well in just four seconds it
can hit 100 km/h and with a top speed of
322 kilometers an hour it outshines many
of its high horsepower competitors
funmi tozzi at 5 meters 30 length
passengers have ample space in the rear
since I note and 625 horsepower make for
exciting driving this Bentley allows for
luxurious high-speed commutes even
though competition is fierce few other
cars offer the same speed and agility
Bentley claims the Flying Spur uses 15
litres per 100 kilometers on average
this proved accurate says vinyl but only
when driving very slowly so which part
of the car's interior is most appealing
only the finest materials are used on
the inside for instance 17 different
types of leather are on offer much is
made by hand and some all four seats are
equally comfortable passengers in the
rear also enjoy an extensive multimedia
system along with ample space and seats
as comfortable as sofas the car's rear
seat leaves little to be desired
reinhold examines the driver's seat the
sedan's 8-speed automatic transmission
is well suited to the Bentley's powerful
output a rocker switch allows drivers to
change gears manually to all switches
are easily accessible but the cars sat
nav is placed rather low and takes the
driver's eyes off the road a large glass
roof adds to the plush interior our
testers verdict
yeah Ben clearest feels it the Flying
Spur was built for those who want to
drive it themselves its suspension
transforms the 2.5 ton vehicle and to a
reasonable sports car it masters country
road curves almost as well as a gulf and
always remains quiet doing so unless
it's fully loaded the only downside says
Reinhold is that the sat-nav system
needs surprisingly long to start up